catholic charities of southern nevada
provides food and nutrition services for
the community as well as a simple way to
give back this holiday season
rocky spoke with deacon tom to learn
more
we are happy to spread this word let's
talk about the catholic charities of
southern nevada obviously you guys have
been around for a long time but some
people
might not know everything you guys do we
are going to celebrate our 80th year
uh next year so it's hard to believe
that uh not too many things are 80 years
old in southern nevada
right but one of them thank god and uh
we do lots of great things
thanks to a very committed team and
wonderful staff and great uh supporters
lots of food resources of food for
people that are homeless or food
insecure on the street
or working but the working poor the food
pantry is
a big asset for people that are trying
to supplement their income
especially under these difficult
circumstances that we're facing
and seniors more than 2
400 seniors are getting food every day
through meals on wheels
and obviously like you said these times
are extra sensitive so can you just tell
us a little bit more
about the food and nutrition programs
you guys have available especially
during the holidays
sure uh we'll probably distribute 3 000
turkeys uh between now and the
thanksgiving holiday uh we'll also
provide the fixins to go along with that
that's through our food pantry and
because of the pandemic we're uh
offering people to come and to be able
to receive those boxes of food
over a table so we're using social
distancing and sanitation
to keep the clients safe as well as our
team many people are taken advantage of
and
in many cases for first-timers i've met
people that were
resort industry folks that are either
laid off or lost their job and so
they're coming for the first time
which is great that we're here but sad
that they're coming
but those assets and those resources for
many of us that kind of take
the ability to feed ourselves and our
families for granted is really important
now
deacon tom tell us more about the daily
community meals and the outdoor dining
pavilions
we provide a free meal every single day
at 10 in the morning seven days a week
for anyone who's food insecure
families and veterans and folks that are
homeless and
people that simply are just down on
their luck or running out of food
especially
towards the end of the month we've
historically served that meal inside of
our dining room
but because of the pandemic and the
inability to social distance in there
we're building an outdoor dining
pavilion which is uh a big tent so it's
our catholic charities under the big top
in order to have about 300 people that
will be able to be seated
uh socially distant and serve this
community meal in a safe environment
also out of the elements and so that
meal will be served every day at 10
uh also the dining pavilion will act as
a day shelter
during the afternoon and it'll be open
for thanksgiving
so just a couple weeks away so we're
excited about it people are donating to
us again online
which is a wonderful way for them to
still be a part of this experience
and you know when conditions allow us to
invite volunteers back we we certainly
want them to come back
some people are volunteering by making
masks and scarves
um virtual volunteering uh which is
wonderful
and we're just grateful for people to
remember that
despite the fact that all of us are
struggling during these times there are
a lot of people in our community
that are really just trying to survive
and we're here to help them
catholic charities of southern nevada is
located at 1501 las vegas boulevard
north
for more information you can call the
number on your screen or visit
catholiccharities.com
there's more las vegas now just ahead